I just thought you should know
I think something a little fishy is
going on a little fishy
that little girl is a child I don't want
to see you sniffing around her anymore
this afternoon do you understand yes
well I have you lost your mind cause
I'll help you find it what you looking
for ain't nobody gonna help you out
there Jesus can come through that door
it's not gonna help you if you don't
stop sniffing after my child okay
Stanley yelled at me today
that was one of the most frightening
experiences of my life
hey dude just got back from Jamaica
[Music]
yeah that sounds amazing but you know
what the lady Jan Levinson want to go to
Montego Bay
well I'm looking at a photo right now
and I'm telling you it could be a maxim
they wouldn't
keep oh no
okay well
check this out
I'm sending you
some email
you got it no I got nothing
check it again hit refresh
okay wait a second I sent it to you
at packer dundermifflin.com
oh
I just got it from somebody else
wow
this is hot damn
how do I get you out of this picture
oh
you're gonna answer that Kevin
all right thanks
Dunder Mifflin this is Kevin
please hold while I transfer you
Oscar your mom
Charles is having Kevin cover the phones
for a while
how do I say this diplomatically
I think Kevin is doing exactly as well
as anyone might have expected someone
like him to perform in a position like
that
please hold
Andy phone call nope stay there
Kev I thought we nailed the whole
transfer thing earlier yeah I wrote it
on my hand but then I washed it it is
transfer extension and then transfer
again okay Andy get ready transfer here
we go extension transfer ah oh man it is
one three four okay come on hustle you
are murdering this is Kevin please hold
and I will transfer you
you're bad at this too don't answer that
call just transfer the damn goal your
call is very important to us please
[Applause]
my maid died
hey check it out there's a there's a
castle over there oh my God there is a
castle
they found a castle Michael
oh God
oh my God he's gonna jump
he's going to kill himself pretending to
kill himself yeah
hey uh
Michael
don't jump on the bouncy castle
you can't do that because you're going
to get horribly horribly injured
hey Michael
I have a present for you but you have to
come down and get it
what is it
come down and open it and you'll see
Dwight find out what the president is
okay uh I don't see anything she might
be bluffing Dwight
everyone thinks the new guys are so cool
because they get Slackline
hey Clark this is what a real salesman
looks like
they say that you only live once and I'm
about to prove it boy truth
[Applause]
at least once a year I like to bring in
some of my Kevin's famous chili the
trick is to undercook the onions
everybody is going to get to know each
other in the pot I'm serious about this
stuff
I'm up the night before pressing garlic
and dicing whole tomatoes I toast my own
ancho chilies
it's a recipe passed down from Malone's
for Generations
probably the thing I do best
I like this maybe a whole theme like a
wrap a wrap rhyme Urban thing an urban
yeah Stanley you want to help us out
with that
Stanley Eartha Stanley not me yes you
come on Stanley put your little game
down and and join the group no Stanley
we're doing having a little bit alone
it's been a brainstorm session
good this is good I'm going to grab a
glass of water
you're blackmailing me it's just
business
I will not be blackmailed by some
ineffectual privileged defeat soft penis
debutante you want to start a street
fight with me bring it on but you're
going to be surprised by how ugly it
gets you don't even know my real name
I'm the Lizard King
bro
what
do you want to tell me something you
look like you want to tell me something
you look like you have something really
important to say and you just can't for
some reason
come on you can tell me
Jim
tell me anything
do this okay ready three
two
one go
okay
so
we're good
absolutely
oh
hold on sorry no second
it's from you
want to grab some dinner
oh yeah
okay and uh I know
everybody says this but I maybe some
Italian there
shiny
oh just so you know
okay buddy
oh
foreign